[Music]
this like when i come into this building
and i hear
like you playing the piano
it was evoking a certain feeling in me
and i was like what's that feeling that
i'm feeling
and it's
it reminds me it reminds me of like
walking into like my old church youth
group
yeah there's like always somebody
playing the piano like you know there's
like people all around like there's you
know people talking and stuff and like
somebody's off like playing some sort of
thing on the piano and
those good memories
yeah yeah great memories yeah
[Music]
this thing of like
it's really uh it's really disturbing
how
often
k i feel like kids are asked like what
they want to do
when they grow up nowadays and they're
like i want to be famous oh yeah i know
you're like oh for doing what doesn't
matter
i just i really like
i don't know it really affects me
the only thing sadder i've ever heard
than that in that vein is that my
husband humphrey told me that
um because he went to school with prince
william um yeah and uh they were in the
same class and when he was when they
were like eight or nine they did this
thing where they asked all the kids what
they wanted to be when they grew up and
um williams said he wanted to be a
police officer and all the kids laughed
because they were like you're not going
to be a police officer you're going to
be the king and i was like that is so
deeply tragic to me that you have this
kid that's like i want to be a police
officer and they're like no you stupid
isn't that sad it's like to think about
that because i think about that all the
time like when that he went to school
with prince william and i'm like it's
not like people that went to school with
george clooney where it's like he wasn't
george clooney when you went to school
with him yeah like prince william was
the prince when he was eight so
everybody that knew him in school was
like you're not normal you're gonna be
the kids like going to school with
emmanuel lewis you're like
man holy [ __ ] it's webster
he's got to be king one day
i can't believe it it's right there
we'd better get in his good graces now
look how he eats his porridge yeah
so much less sloppy than how we do
he's using a spoon
i'll just use my hands
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i really funny stupid question
what are their last names
what
whatever
i was just sitting here thinking like
prince william prince harry
queen elizabeth what the [ __ ] are their
last names
uh that's a good question of windsor
do you not know either i don't i don't
elizabeth alexandra mary windsor it is
windsor
yeah where are the winds of
okay well so well i mean i mean i don't
want to well no okay
between 9 and 9 15 and he'll come in at
9 12. on the text chain the text chain
was i could be there by nine and then
everybody gave a thumbs up oh it was
that we said hey we're going to be out
by like a certain time so and so you
were doing us a service and saying like
you know what i'll i'll make it work
i'll be there at nine yeah we have 15
extra minutes
um so i took it as that but then but but
to be fair to mcelhenny
you know morrow's
email did say arrival between nine and
yes that's true so
we started but it was certainly yeah
look if we're here we're doing bits we
were doing business
yes charlie's always here and sitting
down you roll in around nine and
sometimes you're early but you never sit
down until it's like 9 14. i said that's
fine that's that's right oh yeah you
mean like at night yeah i'm i'm ready i
want to i think we should distinguish no
like what our it's almost like arrive
[ __ ] arrival time like i i'll arrive
whenever the [ __ ] start tell me the
start time and i'll figure out how early
i need to get there well got it
that shirt is real tight it's on the
verge
i mean now here's the thing you're in
very good shape right now and you look
great thanks okay and i mean that in all
seriousness
that shirt is very tight however and i
don't know that it needs to be quite
that tight quite like fitted you mean
it's it's on the verge i'd say you're
pulling you're definitely pulling out is
it tight on caitlyn too
hey
i don't know i feel like almost tucked
in almost looks looks more it justifies
the tightness of the shirt even more
well
i don't think the shirt is going to be
as um
i do like
people as the ankles remember they don't
like
they do not like angles
cover your eyes it's fine i wouldn't
tuck it in it's just um it's so hot and
i felt like this is a summer look you
got to get your linens on i had to get
what this isn't linen that's not but i
do have i do have lynn and i could i
wore it what is it towel
i mean that just looks like a regular
shirt
is it cotton yeah yeah it's kind of
scary does it look like something
special yeah it does i'm seeing like a
texture um
i iced my coffee today since it's so
darn hot it's about a thousand dollars i
got i got a nice coffee too every time i
go to ship it it's throwing me off
because i keep forgetting that i iced it
oh yeah and then i'm like this coffee's
gone cold do you think you're gonna be
all right it's gone freezing cold
are you guys coming in iced today then
is that what's happening coming in i see
cold coming in nice ice cold baby ice
cold yeah hey uh
we were just doing a little uh bit about
um the royal family and uh
i was realizing i don't know their last
names
we we looked it up
do you know often it's the it's the
house of windsor okay so that's it yeah
yeah oh but that's it yeah so you know
you didn't have to tell them the
ultimate answer which is that that that
is actually their last name is that
where you were headed with that yes that
you knew that that yeah not that you
suspected that it was
no i knew that it was
i'll tell you this
prior to the last like six months i knew
very little about the um about the royal
family yeah uh or maybe last year
because then but then i started watching
the crown then i got into it a little
bit and then i now i spent a lot of time
over there mm-hmm what are you doing you
know i own a football team um over there
and they play football over there yeah
they do they play football oh my gosh i
don't think i've ever seen a british
person in a football helmet yeah no no
no no no we call it soccer here uh but
everywhere else in the world they call
it they called ah you're talking about
this game that you kick a ball where you
kick with your foot yeah
and uh no i'm a big fan of american
football too but you know i also have a
documentary series it's launched it's a
big hit but you know you don't you don't
support me i love documentaries
charlie's seen it i love documentaries
walk me through again what channel is it
it's it's it's on the same channel that
sonny's on um fx but it's also on hulu
it's available on hulu
uh congratulations man thank you it's um
it's a very very big hit for them which
feels good now again you guys aren't
really a part of the zeitgeist or or the
culture um and so you wouldn't i don't
know what's in your news feed your new
seat is sort of
food related or
i don't know there's a lot of feed i
don't know what that means i don't get
fed i don't get fed news i i don't yeah
yeah i don't want to be fed so you got
you got a soccer documentary and it's
going i mean a football documentary i
will say you've learned all the last
names of the royal family
and yeah that's a byproduct of just
spending a lot of time okay and you're
feeling overall good about it it's like
my relationship to the royal family or
no the whole thing this has been a good
venture in your life it's been a
positive been a great experience people
seem to be really enjoying the um the
documentary series not you guys but um
millions of people across the globe and
um it's been really fun i'm trying to
get an inside look at uh two rich white
guys and by a football team yeah and i'm
i see this rich white guy all the time
i'm not interested
i'm surrounded by rich white guys
i know your point of view on almost
everything else i don't know that i need
to know what your point of view on
football is no no i'm kidding i will
tune in i will tune in by the way would
you when did it launch yesterday two
days ago last week yeah last week
i think is it appropriate to watch with
miles there's some language things but
other than that yeah there's no like
hardcore graphic sex so you guys aren't
no the players aren't [ __ ] you and
i'm sure they're they're definitely
[ __ ] off camera you and i'm not each
other you and ryan don't uh no but i try
to make it work i mean how do you cover
the dongs up in the locker room do you
just use like oh by the way that did
that does happen they the the cameras go
into the locker room and the boys don't
care and if i look like that and if i
had the dongs you wouldn't carry it i
wouldn't
oh big big strong legs and football
giant
young man
full of testosterone full of
testosterone just balls just filled with
semen
they're ready to explode at any moment
you know i mean just
in every way
it's been a very fun experience and um
and and the show's uh it's it's really
catching on there's a lot millions more
wrexham fans out there so that's nice
yeah i will say i do this very clever on
the on the posters that you guys are
rob
w yes r-o-b and ryan w-r-i-y-a-n
yeah that was very clever making my name
even harder to
spell
i said fx marketing team come up with
that or yeah who came up with that yeah
that was the
they seem to be doing a pretty good job
yeah they are good yeah so you know if
you guys can you can check it out you
know no i'm gonna watch i'm gonna watch
i'm gonna watch it with miles i mean uh
it's a perfect thing to watch with him
because he's obsessed with uh soccer
yeah yeah it's a it's a and you don't
really have to even love soccer to love
the documentary
you don't really love a good doc yeah
you don't really even get into soccer
until the end of the second episode so
it's really more about the town and the
people of the town and then you get
invested okay okay okay yeah we'll be
sure to watch
thank you yeah welcome to the podcast
everybody it's a giant commercial for a
show that you don't care about
well i am really excited about today
because we um asked podcast listeners
and creeps to send in videos to prove
that they're the most philly in honor of
us going to philly for our first live
shows later this month
um and we got so many really funny
submissions and one dick
so that was pretty good though yeah like
somebody sent a video of their data it
was funny or was it was it a video or
was it a still pick it was a video
oh i'm not like hanging it around
those are pretty good numbers right
though like just one dick for all the
video submissions yeah that's pretty
good it's probably pretty good it's
probably pretty what how many video
submissions did we get in total um what
like 150 maybe yeah yeah one out of
every 150 okay
all right so we picked some favorites
and i've got all of these people in a
waiting room on zoom to meet you guys
right now so what we're going to do is
show you their submission video so you
get to meet them and then one by one
we'll bring them on great you guys just
get to talk to them you can just talk to
them about stuff but they're all super
fans of the podcast and you guys so
great really excited to show you
something like that
and if you want to you can give people
tickets to the live show if it's people
that are in philly and want to go some
of them already have tickets but okay if
you feel like offering anybody okay i'll
just mark it down and we'll give them
free tickets okay are we starting with
the disc
are we starting why with the dick uh no
i wasn't going to show that to you guys
unless you want to see oh i do
for as abusive as it is for you to
receive dicks or mara and you and you
have experienced that over and over
again we don't get to experience
um
it could be good to start off with it i
mean just to get the juices
let's go ahead and see what we're
dealing with
what does the tattoo say oh
i'm starting to regret this already okay
i'm a little nervous oh you can hear it
oh you son of a [ __ ] all right
oh is that we gotta go oh my god oh oh
oh oh
oh
wow
yeah
yeah yeah
that's the problem with sending a dick
pic it's just never what you hoped
no well you realize very quickly that
you don't want to have anything to to do
with it you know what i mean
i just and i also i don't know if i want
to encourage this guy you know no great
okay well let's get started meeting
these people if you guys are down let's
do it um i'd like to start with caitlyn
please um
and if you guys want to hear these just
put your headphones on
and you can leave them on because also
when we zoom with people that's how
you'll hear them okay
hi hans my name is kate i'm from
northeast philadelphia born and raised
and i'm an affiliate because i actually
refuse to watch your shape for e just
people like it's so funny and i was like
no i'm from philly like it's just gonna
be stereotypical like that's not funny
like whatever and then this guy i've
been dating for like three years now we
first started hooking up with a little
you know netflix and chill situation a
couple of times and
it'd be so funny i'd be like laughing
even though we were banging like i think
i'd be laughing even though we were
back love you guys go birds big fan
okay all right i have a few questions
that's an amazing accent amazing and
i wonder if she's turning it on a little
bit it feels a little bit modulated that
she's putting it on
my brother my brother patrick here is uh
oh you know her
you couldn't hear that did you feel as
that though that accent was a little
juiced up a little juiced right i think
that that is right but she turned it up
for laughs well we're gonna find about
to meet her exactly
okay hi hon how are you
where he's from
i'm from northeast philly mayfair
specifically oh mayfair i have lots of
friends from from mayfair
hey hon did you go to st mats
no i went to sing tim's okay of course
it's either matt's or tim's over there
we were debating uh based on your uh the
video that you sent in whether you were
turning on the accent just a little bit
more were you just we did you dial it up
a little bit for the video
oh of course oh yeah okay just a little
bit all right
yeah it was pretty good
you got to know your audience
yeah yeah now you were introduced to the
show by your boyfriend
yeah so i like refused to watch it for
years i just like completely wrote it
off honestly like i didn't even i didn't
look you guys up you could have been
from philly i had no idea i was just
like that's going to be about philly
it's going to be corny i'm not going to
watch it but then he was like no like
you have to watch it and like i wanted
to hook up with him so i'd watch it
like i would actually hear it
and it would be funny i'd be like wait a
second that joke was good
well now i'm hearing that the the accent
was not turned up that much not that
much yeah this is nice
finding out that our show is sometimes
used as a tool of sexual manipulation
okay all right what's what's that
necklace you have on
that is this one yeah it's a carnelian
crystal and then my grandmother's old
brain
philadelphia people love heirlooms
yes
i got everybody's got like their
are you coming to the live show are you
coming to the podcast no i didn't get
tickets i didn't get tickets but i
should have we should have gone yeah you
should have well but we might be able to
remember we might be able to offer
probably figure that out
i'm thinking of a number between one and
one hundred what is it
yeah
you got it
it wasn't it wasn't but it doesn't
matter it was it wasn't but it doesn't
matter you got it you won the ticket now
if you perfect if you bring your
boyfriend can you assure us that you
guys aren't going to bang during the
show oh
i can't promise but
yeah yeah yeah yeah no promises nice to
meet you caitlyn we'll see you at the
live show i'll see you guys there bye
thanks so much
and bye
okay great next we're going to watch
robert's video
robert
okay robert i'm going to explain to you
really quick why i am the most
philadelphia out of all philadelphians
now like most philadelphians i keep a
framed photograph of my uncle and my
father
right let me explain to you both these
fellows were were born and raised in a
fairmount uh philadelphia pennsylvania
he died of a drug overdose and my dad
became a cop and there is nothing more
philadelphia than that okay
this person is amazing
i love this guy he looks like he's like
a young matt greening right yeah that
person what's his name robert roberts
robert so bringing
in
robert
hello
oh hi hi
what's up man all right you on your
commute i hope i'm just hanging out in a
parking lot right now okay now what's
the parking lot and why are you there
so um i'm in virginia right now because
i my parents bought a cabin here so they
had they decided to bring me down
right when i'm going to do this podcast
and there's no internet at the cabin
so i had to make the trek to this holy
land which is the exxon gas station
about 20 minutes away
[Laughter]
i've come down here just to speak with
you guys uh don't feel flattered or
anything
but thank you for having me on i'm
extremely grateful yeah man uh
it's very unfilly of you to not be in
philly yeah but we'll have to call that
up but that's you know that's just bad
luck what are you driving there what
what what are you in is that a this is
uh mom's van that's a van okay that's a
van it's mom's van chilling out in here
it's hot as hell out
and um having some fun
um
so my dad's my dad's from fairmount my
grandparents still live in philadelphia
about two blocks away from eastern state
penitentiary also yeah of course that's
very close to my high school so was your
dad a cop in bethlehem or in philly he
was a cop in philly he um worked for the
housing authority in the 1990s how old
are you robert
about 17 years old 17 young man how long
you been growing that hair out buddy
uh probably for the uh fat uh past two
years over the uh the horrible dark
times of the
virus sorry can you tell us what month
you were born in
june 19th
uh this television show is older than
you
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
how old are you again sorry
you're 17. you're 17 17 years old like
to the year i mean you were born in 2005
i was born 2005 june 19 2005. yeah when
did the show first error august of 2005.
yeah which means we had shot the
television series oh we'd shot it yes
yes so it was it was birthed so in a
sense you are the show it's basically
his age
um are you coming to the live show
i would love to uh unfortunately i'm
broke as hell so you know that's a
barrier between me and the show here
yeah it's a barrier between most things
in life got it
let's just give him the give give the
kid a ticket right
[Music]
we are supported by athletic greens
you guys eat breakfast this morning who
has time for breakfast i drink the
leftover milk from my son's cereal bowl
on the way out the door that's what you
mean right well guys i think it's high
time you get on that ag-1 train i don't
know you know i bought into that whole
wheat grass movement in the 90s and that
didn't do much for my physique listen no
hard sell here just trying to keep my
boys healthy
and sharp i take it
and i love it okay with just one single
scoop of ag-1 you're getting 75.
that's right 75 high quality vitamins
minerals superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to kick your day off right
well you do seem uh sprightly you know
what i mean you got a good pep in your
step and to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is you gotta
go to
athleticgreens.com that's all yeah this
is athleticgreens.com to take ownership
over your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance
when we started this podcast we had to
make sure we set ourselves up for
success yeah and you know look it's been
a process you know i mean we started out
just doing an audio doing audio episodes
you know then we started filming video
and just random offices and [ __ ] you
know and now we've got our very own
studio
yup we've even got merch and uh and
we're about to have our first live shows
which i know we're all pretty excited
about it's a full blown operation here
that meg is running meg has been running
the show megan's running the show really
is a big operation we're very grateful
to her and thank you for all the creeps
and listeners out there for sticking
with us while megan figures out what the
show is and tells us
what it is what we're supposed to be
doing and saying yes now charlie you
mentioned merch a second ago and i'm i'm
sure you guys remember the bumps that we
hit when we uh launched our merch store
oopsy daisy
uh i've got a feeling that we could have
avoided all that if
only we had used
shipstation you're right because
shipstation software is the number one
choice for online sellers do you know
who uses shipstation our pal nick
offerman for his small business offerman
woodshop is that that guy is so cool
he's so cool that he emasculates me
every time he shows up on screen i feel
emasculated yeah i'm talking about it
makes me miss my mustache
you may not have a mustache like his
anymore but uh this is another way you
can be like him all right go to
shipstation.com
okay that's ship
station.com today and sign up with promo
code sunny
for a free 60-day trial
all right the next person we're going to
meet is darius johnson
what's the phillies thing about you uh
school is my safe word not philly enough
gum all right i want some cheese steaks
and crimpings into the franklin
institute and ate them in the heart not
philly enough go all right [ __ ] it i had
an orgy with kevin hart pink quest love
tina fey and bradley cooper the philly
fanatic on accept the bus and that [ __ ]
was crazy boys and men were on the side
and they sung angelic backup vocals it
was amazing that we went through so much
water you guys wouldn't believe it at
the end we climaxed the sound was so
beautiful we needed another crack in the
liberty bell will smith wasn't there but
he said it slapped
all right
he put on a show
he put some effort into this
on the toilet
all right um guys please meet darius
darius can you turn on your camera and
meet the guys
[Applause]
there he is
oh
there he is darius thank you for putting
so much effort into your video yeah you
actually you actually wrote you put a
whole bit together that was great
thank you you know i had to okay what's
the deal now are you are you is this uh
a common thing for you writing bits are
you an actor or are you a performer in
some
i am yes i'm an actor
okay that comes through that comes
through
how's that going good looking guy is it
is it there a lot of stuff happening in
philly acting-wise yeah are you
are you professionally having to go into
new york for stuff yeah
i actually moved to sunny la with you
guys
hello you live in los angeles that's
what i love
what party what part of philly are you
from
from like the fairmont area kind of like
uh spring garden that air but i've lived
all over i mean i went to westchester
outside of philly in the bucks county
area all over wow okay yeah so there's a
lot of fair amounts showing up today
yeah that's that's where my high school
was coming because i've been to fairmont
okay yeah spring gardens
um where
uh in la area
and koreatown all right
philadelphia of los angeles
i don't know
pretty much um would you like to see if
you well you don't you're not going to
come to the live show because you don't
live in the city you're all the way over
here darius what you were you got
anything you need to plug while you're
here
what are you working on yeah what are
you working on man
uh what am i working on uh
my mental health okay yeah yeah yeah
well we are that's
that's why we came to hollywood that's
what we're all working on
um but uh
yeah i just uh
been working on an animated series
that's going to be released on
nickelodeon next month hey oh we got a
gig pretty much is all all i can say but
uh it's coming out around uh like the
halloween time it's going to be a big
deal because it's something that was
from childhood that's kind of you know
in the reboot you know era so halloween
sounds like a scooby-doo type thing but
uh i'm not gonna you know force you to
say because let's see
uh that's cool that sounds fun and so do
you have an agent are you uh
you've got private agent manager or you
yeah
yeah asian and manager nice man nice all
right man what do you think make your
[ __ ] make your own [ __ ] make your own
[ __ ] and uh you know in the meantime
well hopefully we will uh invite you to
the uh live show but you're not gonna go
so uh kick butt here in l.a and uh well
how about this how about this we gotta
get you to audition for the show how
about that we'll
we'll
so when we when we write this next uh
season um you know we'll we'll we'll
send your info over to our casting
director and we'll see if we can get you
in for something
for something that would be cool
[ __ ] love that
awesome that'd be amazing all right
awesome
darius
nice to meet you appreciate you guys so
much bye-bye
bye
um great so next we have
michelle
hi my name is michelle
i'm the phillies of the philly because
um well i'm from northeast philly born
and raised
also
i am a die-hard sports fan like you know
we tend to be in philly
however
i cannot stand the eagles
do not like the eagles i have a strong
distaste for the eagles
so my philly
mentality is
when they went to the super bowl played
the patriots in the super bowl i left
town i took a trip to new york went for
two days by myself
um because i had to leave the city
just because i couldn't stand them that
much it's a philly move
philly
mentality
so many questions yeah a lot of
questions a lot of questions
well let's get into it let's get into it
hi michelle
hi can you see me yeah
hey
well we've got questions we got
questions yeah a lot of questions over
here i've shown the guys your video that
you sent in so they have questions for
you question number one what is written
on your knuckles
um so it's ray
um it's my boyfriend's name he passed
away in 2020. i'm so sorry
okay terrible thank you for asking
oh god i'm so sorry to hear that um he
was a huge eagles fan by the way too
well well but now okay now now my
question is
even more questions so when so you say
you claim to be an eagle a philadelphia
sports fan
is that right um well there's only a few
organizations in the city and you happen
to hate the one one of them did she say
she was a philadelphia sports fan did
she say she was a big sports fan a
philly sports man okay phil yeah okay so
i am late yeah like i'm a huge sports
fan um
huge phillies fan and i'm a huge union
fan i don't really follow hockey anymore
wait can i guess
can i guess yeah what what happened here
you had some sort of a a run-in with an
actual eagle
you know what it's so funny someone else
said that too one of my other friends
mentioned that before too he's like
that's the only reason why you could
like hate them that much but no it's not
true no okay so you you did not you did
not encounter an eagle and get into some
sort of a situation with this bird where
you felt uncomfortable or threatened and
are you an actor
you're talking about the bird
not a player not a person
no no no no an actual eagle who you know
gave her the eagle eye yeah got it okay
okay so so we so so it's not with an
eagle no not with a player
do you hate the color green um
no i don't need the color all right
she's gonna tell us what do you hate
champions
[Laughter]
no i'm a patriots fan oh
that's why now how did that happen to
you
you know i don't know so i understand
why people like hated and they roll
their eyes and they like make fun of me
but
i don't know i was never an eagles fan i
never connected with them for some
reason even though i'm a huge sports fan
i've been watching sports since i could
like
understand
words and pictures now so you hate the
eagles do you hate it's always sunny in
philadelphia do you hate us no are you
kidding me it's my favorite show look i
have another i don't know if you can see
but i have another poster
let's let's see what you got because
we're not actually uh
i love that that's the best one
now we're not affiliated with the eagles
in any actual way so
no or actual eagles the birds no well
no no i feel like we should ask her
first of all do you have tickets to the
live uh podcast
i have tickets to the monday show yeah
the sunday show sold out like instantly
so well we have tickets for the sunday
joe if you want would you want to come
to both yes absolutely can we get you
those tickets all right see there go
birds go birds
okay um next we are going to have connor
now connor is very special because
connor tried to send in his videos seven
times
and then he eventually had to have his
mother send it in for him um which was
very sweet um and so i imagine we were
having fun imagining a lot of screaming
in their household of like mom it's not
sending english
now connor i believe likes the eagles
and here is connor i believe he likes
this football team
hello i'm connor i'm 20 years old about
to be 21. um i live about an hour and 30
minutes outside of philadelphia been an
eagles fan my whole life
as you can see here in my room all eagle
stuff got the always sunny in
philadelphia stuff i've been an always
sunny fan since i was about 11 years old
um the show's almost as old as me which
i think is crazy
i would love to meet you can tell i'm
out of breath can't even breathe if you
can give me a chance to meet you guys
go birds
go birds
connor welcome to the podcast can you
turn on your video and meet the guys
can you turn your videos
[Music]
i am now yeah yeah i can tell that was
the basement i don't know how i could
tell but i could tell connor question
for you are do you have tickets to the
uh to the podcast live show
yeah it's the live at the met yeah i
think you have tickets to that already
you're saying no haven't bought it okay
now you realize um which which which
night would you like to go the sunday
night or the monday night whatever night
works
well i see that you're a big eagles fan
i have i have some bad news
unfortunately
it's going to be the the the time of the
monday night um show is the exact time
of the eagles home opener on monday
night that was smart that's smart of us
yeah that was i i tried to get out of it
as soon as the nfl we actually booked it
before the nfl schedule came out and
then as soon as i found out i i emailed
everybody and said anyway we can change
it and meg was like no no
you called the nfl you're like i'm also
a sports team owner can we you know
anyway
um i also want the football timing
though that was hilarious if you were at
the live show what would you want to see
i'm just curious as a as a supervisor
what i want to see yeah i mean
i mean people are there just to see you
so i think that's the number one thing
but i mean i we just want to hear you
guys talk like how you guys honestly do
it like we don't want don't get the um
fans involved too much i hate that
connor i hate to break it to you but
you're experiencing it right now yeah
you are in it you are it you are who you
are you are what you hate right now okay
it's happening i have to be what i hate
well let's get this guy to the show
if you guys saw the video to get on here
whoever picked it i want to thank them
because i almost passed out making a
video yeah
yeah yeah we could tell that we could
tell almost died almost died
yeah thank you very much i appreciate it
yeah if you get a chance to actually
i'll meet you guys again in the future
yeah you too buddy
for life yeah thank you
um
this is natalie what up
what makes me more philly than the rest
is the fact that i got my daily
breakfast sandwich i am right across the
street from a bar i'm on my way to work
and
i work in the alley that you guys feel
oh
from the gang turns blackened
are you doing a little musical oh that
is that
yeah this is where i work um
i think i'm more affiliate than the rest
of you i ran down broad street when the
birds won go birds uh peace love gritty
and i literally live around the corner
from the paddy's in old city
wow it's pretty philly pretty now eating
a sandwich on your way to work is not
necessarily philly centric that's a
thing that i think a lot of people eat
sandwiches
a lot of people don't know that in
philly people eat sandwiches elsewhere
breakfast sandwiches they get breakfast
sandwiches they go to work they do that
hi
oh you're at work now everybody's at
work i am glad that our listeners and
creeps have jobs yeah and it's late over
there so you've had your sandwich
already yes
it's noon or 1 30 where i am okay okay
so you had your breakfast sandwich and
now you've also had your lunch sandwich
and uh what else did you pack in your
lunch bag today did mommy get you an
apple or
now what's going on in the alleyway
where we did the gang turns black uh
that's what what kind of what kind of
offices we have in there
um
so if you're looking down the alley from
13th street on the left is
apartments and then on the right
the ground floor i don't know what it
was when you filmed it but now it's a
european wax center and then above that
is an architecture firm a european wax
center isn't a place to go get a a wax
get your bits and bobs waxed
i don't know european wax center yeah i
don't know okay are you on a phone are
you mobile right now
i'm on my computer mm-hmm
what would you do can you call us back
on the phone and i want you to go into
that place and find out what the [ __ ] it
is
what does european wax mean
what are you are you purchasing wax are
you getting waxed yeah to call it a
scent you're getting waxed i think
you're getting waxed but i i i think um
do europeans do it differently than
than in the us they do everything
different you know i mean just like a
little off a major chain of hair removal
salons
okay major major i was going to call
them
now are you coming to the live show that
we're doing of this podcast
i was in denmark when those tickets went
on sale and i missed it well good news
for you we have extra tickets wait wait
would she like to go would you like to
would you like to i would love to go all
right
[Music]
[Applause]
now a word from our sponsor better help
what's going on glenn you seem a little
blue talk to me goose
yeah well i'm i'm um i guess i'm having
a i'm i'm having a little problem the
rashes are back right the rashes are
back but that's not it i i uh
i guess i'm just i'm having a little
trouble figuring out you know what it
all means i don't know if we're
qualified to uh give you the answers of
the universe and uh you might need
better help okay now wait do you mean
better help like superior assistance
which could come from almost anybody
other than us or do you mean better help
like the online therapy company now
that's actually not a bad idea yeah
what is that better help oh it's an
affordable accessible and convenient
online alternative to in-person therapy
you fill out a brief survey and you get
matched with the therapist okay and if
it doesn't feel like the right fit you
switch therapists anytime ah geez i
don't know does therapy really work i
think that's just it right it's doing
the work teaching yourself to stay in
problem-solving mode yeah i like the
sound of that
when you want to be a better problem
solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
sunny today to get 10 percent off your
first month that's better
h-e-l-p-com
sunny i'm gonna do it
the always sunny podcast is supported by
visa our characters on the show have had
a lot of big ideas over the years and
now
we're not saying that all of the ideas
were good ideas no no no they're mostly
mostly bad ideas almost entirely i don't
know some of them were pretty good like
um some some kittens out there they need
mittens you know anyway you look at it
they don't have enough fur on their paws
and they want to keep them warm okay one
that i personally think um
that did have a lot of potential fight
milk
because alcohol historically has had not
it just hasn't had enough nutritional
value buddy on the market you know what
i mean i can't agree with you more there
okay you know what the problem is though
with all these ventures is that our
characters never really had the support
you need to get to get these ideas off
the ground right you need some backup
you need some support they needed
visa
yeah oh really visa
okay yes visa has the power to help
bring your game changing ideas to life
that's right yeah visa anyone can change
the game
[Music]
and this is
uh billy he's got a miller highlight
this whole thing looks good greetings
and [ __ ] salutations how you doing
it's mr monday night mr two dollar
tuesday mr white girl wasted wednesday
mr thursday thursday mr freaky friday mr
silky saturday and my personal [ __ ]
favorite mr sunday fun day how you doing
billy joe marrero over here i just won't
let you know ain't no guy
more philly than this [ __ ] guy how
you doing cuz
well that beer looks good doesn't it
hey
oh he's got a whole set up his own
podcast wait a minute wait a minute
what's going on here
oh look he's got his butt oh
guys hey he's
wait a minute this is a trip man you
you're you're you've got a whole setup
over there
are you recording your own podcast over
there what are you doing
no negative
i do music so that's why i got the fancy
stuff
let's talk about this championship belt
behind you are you the champion do you
have a
are you no that's a that's a stone cold
steve awesome replica
but it's leather and it's gold-plated
it's legit oh so it's heavy it's got the
it's got the weight to it yeah okay so
you don't want that to come crashing
down it's not the maniacs replica
oh have been good
now what about now i noticed your boy i
don't see yours but i noticed your boy
had a miller high life and it is what is
it 1 30 there over there no no no no
we're doing bogs oh
okay i thought you just had stitches
taken out so uh i called out to work and
i told my girl i was like if i'm calling
out of work
i'm gonna get smacked when i'm talking
to the guys all right okay
so how many
three four five across number you're on
six yeah okay so you're since eight
though so that's not bad right no it's
not unknown no that's actually well
paced yeah i think so i think it's well
yeah and then where's your boy how many
this is i got two my homies i got my boy
fiddler here what's up fiddler fiddler
very close to diddler great bullet oh
the ball is in the box
i can cuss right yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
awesome
you look like a sports guy so i grew up
in a very blue collar
south philly family
but um but as a little boy i had an
affinity for a theater music greece was
like my favorite uh movie growing up so
oh nice okay you're my favorite caller
so far i like this guy
you are fascinating you're very good you
guys
are very very familiar
uh what kind of music what kind of music
you making over there you'd be making
the rock and roll to make the kids are
the kids bopping to it
i'm gonna be honest with you i do not by
the way megan uh it's it's it's great to
see you i you are such a
nice breath of fresh air considered to
these guys yeah that's right i love that
you made that gesture and then talked
about how i was
like
i just want to i just want to reach out
and grab you you know
[Laughter]
what kind of music you make
so
jeez louise that's such a weird question
to ask um
it's not a weird question to ask
actually it's uncomfortable to answer
because it feels a bit pretentious well
why don't you
why don't you not explain it why don't
you play some of it oh there we go i
think you should i think you should go
with um uh uh
back to life that's the best
i like that guys
[Music]
that's amazing from the guy that taught
me the dentist system
all right listen man are you coming to
the live show
i want to come to the live show i need
to know what date it is because my son
is a football player now he's 14. he's
in high school so i need to whoa wait
what wait how old are you no no no no no
i'm 35. um
yeah you started young okay
no i'm puerto rican we start young okay
um well it's september 18th and 19th
it's a sunday and a monday night it's a
sunday night and a monday night i get
paid tomorrow i'm buying the tickets fun
fact when the eagles won the super bowl
the super bowl parade i lost two pairs
of shoes in one day
wow that's great i lost shoes and then
someone was like oh man
i always wonder how that happens how do
you lose your shoes i have no idea to be
honest with you they also smacked
yeah yeah that's what happens
all right well you got the tickets for
tickets
[Laughter]
great we'll get some for your buddies
there too so
yeah
classy fancy literally around the corner
from me
wow you can walk and you probably should
walk you should probably walk
[Laughter]
bring four pairs of shoes
[Laughter]
well we'll see you at the show oh my god
thank you so much guys we'll see you at
the show all right dude great to meet
you man thank you thank you very much
pleasure to meet you guys all right
bye-bye
thanks everybody for coming and we'll
see you at the live shows live show